[Music]
before Wayne and guard Harry and Lloyd
Ashton ended stipler one film would
bring something original to the two dumb
guys being dumb John rrah
time travel Bill & Ted's Excellent
Adventure meet Bill and Ted a couple of
valley boys who hang out together rock
out together and say the exact same
words together
Waterloo 69 dudes no way excellent
oh yes how's it going these of course
pace sounds good missing the kid they
may not be smart but they've got a
message of love for all mankind be
excellent to each other just not in a
gay way
uh yeah totally forgot about that
one moving on sit back and say whoa at
Star Keanu Reeves who looks exactly like
he did in the 80s and maybe sodas outs
winter I don't know as Keano debuts the
dumb surfer character he would spend his
entire career trying to get away from
you're trying to tell me the FBI is
going to pay me to learn to surf
eventually Oh any time now there it is
nice dude join their epic adventure
through history all to pass a final exam
we're instead of using a time machine to
help with their studying they'll use it
to violently abduct historical figures
like a game of human Pokemon let's bag
him let's back and it's sure a future
where they become our dystopian God at
first what you believe George Carlin
when he said it was a paradise everyone
lives in the cave and barely speaks wake
up sheeple they're just like evil Biff
and back to the future to chill up for
the rare time travel story that doesn't
get all hung up in that boring paradox
stuff we can't forget to do this
otherwise it won't happen but if then
happen and enjoy a light-hearted romp
that's like Donnie Darko with fart jokes
Luper with keyboard solos it's like back
to the future with mommy issues um more
mommy issues
it's your mom dude it's just mom just
got a minor oedipal complex so take a
while right through time in this cult
classic full of classic lines strange
things are afoot at the circle-k husband
for Peru classic CGI and classic
historical figures you'll remember way
more clearly than whatever you were
taught in history class like how this
dictator loved ice cream and water
slides this violent criminal was a real
ladies man and the biggest mass murderer
in human history was absolutely adorable
oh look at the little guy go he killed
more people than Hitler
starring bill S Preston Esquire wait
how's the student lawyer doctor wah way
ahead of his time and an American TARDIS
duh and duh really guitar players no
base no vocals guys I think the wild
stallions might have always sucked be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers
thanks to honest trailer superfans Jen
chieh Cody P and Rodrigo B for voting
for this honest trailer and for making
Fan Appreciation Month extra special
tune in next week to see what movie the
fans picked for us to make a trailer up
next and while you're waiting
click the box on the left to enjoy more
honest trailers or the box to the right
for our take on the biggest movies
coming out in 2017 be excellent to each
other party on dudes
centi miss high school football rules
speak up I can't hear you through the
sound of my awesome voice if Liam and
Lisa Neeson least a Nissan which Nissan
will Lehman Lisa Neeson Lee's